dunkirk was directed by Christopher
Nolan and stars Tom Hardy Killian Murphy
Kenneth Branagh amongst a humungous cast
of people and tells a story of the
evacuation of 400 thousand men in the
middle of World War two who had every
second are in danger of being eliminated
by the Germans and it's about how these
men got off of those shores the
civilians that got in their own personal
boats to travel there to help them and
the stories of these men trying to do
everything they possibly can to survive
naturally I was excited for this movie I
think most people who love movies are
because it's directed by Christopher
Nolan and so obviously you're instantly
thinking to yourself okay at the very
least this is going to be a magnificent
spectacle and Dunkirk utilizes real
boats real planes real locations
humongous amounts of extras to immerse
you in this moment to make you feel so
completely taken over by it and it works
this movie is thrilling
imagine Michael Bay's Pearl Harbor say
what you want about that movie it's not
good but cut out the first like 90
minutes and the film just starts with
the attack on Pearl Harbor and the rest
of the movie is the attack and that's
the whole film from the opening shot of
Dunkirk you are in it we're introduced
to a few characters very quickly and
then you are instantaneously in this
battle and it never lets up there's
never a dull moment there's never a
scene where characters sit around a
campfire and say who do you got at home
wait for you yeah my wife's pregnant
I got a kid in school well actually the
school ain't there anymore cuz the Nazis
blew it up Oh boohoo there's never a
moment like that you don't get those
moments that you're so used to seeing in
war films and sometimes that can be a
hindrance on the film as well because my
one major issue with this movie which
doesn't detract from it too much is that
I didn't feel a specific connection with
any one character like I wanted to root
for them or I connected with them
emotionally in fact I suppose who you
might view as the audience character the
one young person that you're introduced
to in the opening scene barely speaks a
word for the first half of the movie
this movie is about the event it's about
this evacuation of all of these men it's
about being in the middle of a horrific
situation my buddy who I saw the movie
with Craig said it best he said when you
are in a situation like this you don't
go hey my name is Ben no that's cool my
name is Kevin you know what do you like
oh I don't know there's bombs all over
the place right now and I was just
hoping we could have a nice conversation
this movie is in the moment and the way
Noland Helms all of these battle
sequences
it's what film was invented for
everything on the screen looks
completely authentic there's never a
moment that feels wasted there's not a
scene that feels misplaced and although
it's very simplistic in its
characterization its storytelling isn't
and I don't want to get into why because
I feel that that would be spoiler
territory but there's a moment in this
film where I saw a character in the
nighttime and I went wait a second I
like the film is about an hour and 46
minutes which is very short for Noland
and when I found that out I was
surprised by it but since the film
begins in the battle and ends in the
battle and it's just a battle it's one
gigantic sequence told in a very
interesting way and the runtime I think
is perfect because if it had gone on any
longer I think would have outstayed its
welcome if it was any shorter there
wouldn't have been enough impact the
impact of this movie emotionally doesn't
come from you going I hope that that
person makes it out of this situation so
he can get home to his family
it comes from seeing this spectacle some
might not like that it is about the
spectacle the aerial dogfights sequences
with Tom Hardy whose eyeballs act very
well in this film that poor guy is
always gonna wear a mask I think and
everything he's gonna have something
over his face those dogfights
are so riveting and so white-knuckled
because they look authentic the planes
don't blow up in theatrical ways the
gunfire does not look like movie gunfire
everything about it just feels so
scarily real that despite the fact that
the characters aren't really given much
set up and this movie is 100% about this
moment I was riveted from seeing one
because I felt like I was there Hans
Zimmer's score once again something he
does with Nolan movies it's not so much
melodical as it is almost sound design
and I am still playing these noises in
my head and I will be purchasing the
soundtrack and I can't wait to hear it
again if you go into Dunkirk expecting a
one two three four five straightforward
narrative with characters with emotional
arcs and big moments where they explode
with incredible dialogue you're not
going to get that this movie as I said
is very simplistic but it's also highly
realistic people die in war and
sometimes people die alone terrified
having no idea what's going on and does
that person get an amazing arc or is
someone there to tell them everything's
going to be okay not always and this
film doesn't shy away from showing that
yes there's not too much blood it's
pg-13 there are no limbs flying around
there's no intense gruesome imagery but
it's the psychological impact on all of
the characters involved with this movie
that make it so frightening because
you're witnessing characters who are so
horrified by what they're seeing or by
what they feel could happen to them they
are all desperately clawing to get out
and the ones who are trying to go in to
help you also feel for them the whole
film captures this event so beautifully
that it's tough to really pinpoint any
magnificently huge flaws beyond the fact
that the characters are lacking I'm
gonna give Dunkirk an a excellent war
films like Saving Private Ryan are about
characters in a horrible situation
they're about seeing these people react
to war Dunkirk is just about war and how
horrific aliy terrifying it can be when
you're stuck in the middle of it and
it's definitely worth seeing see it on
the biggest screen you can guys thank
you so much as always for watching
please do check out my previous Nolan
reviews that I've done I have now
reviewed all of his films on my channe
there's a playlist for that very soon
and my next series is going to be
Stephen King movies leading up to the
Dark Tower and it I have a ton of
Stephen King reviews planned and I can't
wait to do that for you guys
you guys are the best thank you very
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]